dude I've had over half this bottle of
bourbon at this point everybody clap
your hands in three
oh sorry sorry one clap got good [ __ ]
enough huh
Oh guys one good [ __ ] it's when you
clap at the same time we got like one
episode out left to do cuz I don't think
I'm gonna last to another my commands
are working Oh God close my mercy thank
you guys so much for doing this
like I love o cuz I had the time the
typing up I love doing this guys you
guys are awesome we should um mission
make a series yeah a what
I'm not gonna lie that statement was
just meant to be um um
throw away oh yeah
like it's like liquid the 76ers in
basketballs old uniforms what that's
close back oh by the pan when hell is
going on
I didn't worse small you want to refill
this is neat to have all the time this
is a funny joke plank yes this is funny
house other like anti funny jokes oh not
as good as these the truth comes out
from zombie mold but zombies try to say
Marga's are you sucking I'm funny
the zombies that we're like right on the
thin line between we're on the cusp of a
super elation drunk zombie tell me how
you feel free to drink and record it's
gonna be an episode of mark pouring his
heart out about whatever bothers mark
and way talking about brain tumor and
everything Oh
minecraft crashed again what are you
doing what is that Tommy what are you
doing my game crashed again oh I'm still
at the roller coaster guys we got us oh
you know what you know keep your webcam
ha ha my gargled i gargled in booze
my makeup I garbled my Hawaiian drafts 3
2 1 Boop okay welcome back guys to let's
play minecraft the drunk let's place the
love of God record something that's
gonna go on YouTube I have things about
you just we're starting
we did we did stars Amba can I join the
server without it crashing the server's
Clyde a mine the wrong one yeah I
haven't crashed yet
Oh Ida server zombie port me to where I
need to go cuz I server I can't be okay
good so what are we doing now
I wasn't gonna say my name before the
things I sell is December Queen
she's um hot she's got powers
this is bang quite creative mode what's
happening here you is that German you're
all right of voting we're gonna build up
pedis really Wow this turned into a
porno Bob are you yeah dirt castle oh
god no I love my life
alright hey um what's this what's this
episode about before we start penis
penis this is an episode that's a
throwback to mark's desires let's get
started i made a joke there guys about
mark and being homosexual
so i'll being homosexual there is
nothing wrong with Mark being homosexual
because it's a funny is an actuality he
prefers sheep oh [ __ ] but he's do bash
hey guys
all right let's pause the recording so I
can get centered in my vodka again okay
yeah just sit in your chair all right
all right um all right we have to we
have to start barks oh god this has
gotta be this has gotta be like the last
one we have to start although I don't
want to stop started a while ago
Oh like so what are we doing
I don't like Mohawk I'm gonna blow
things oh my god was that zombies voice
oh my god
possibly holy cow this just got this
just got an r-rating cuz Ami's voice is
so sexy
it's like Morgan Freeman all of my fans
wanna bang zombie mole
don't don't don't don't oh my fan it's a
good thing sexual relations as this
testicle appropriately that is evil are
you making a testicle for the giant
penis I was trying I'm making a testicle
for this I didn't make it an odd number
though so I can't give it the extra
blocks that it really needs to get that
final pizazz can laughs Tommy can latin
hear me I'll type it out it looks more
like a gob stopped bein girls wanna bang
zombie mold so bad it would you suck so
my hunger for the D they be thirsty girl
mark you're as dumb as you were back in
episode the first no this is not zombie
are you sure this is the kind of you er
that we need to have I think I think
this mark are you invisible again oh did
you see me for no I just saw blocks
being placed along the penis for no
reason here I think this should be
stopped before it close enough did you
tie I can't see who's typing [ __ ] I
can't either my name is
like fans like Zorro zombie is the
sexiest and wanna steal him away from
Latin Oh
our back yeah I'm in creative mode you
can't do [ __ ] to me that was me mark
that was you I'd have smite powers and
there's a slime in my balls I didn't
mean like literally look at it it's all
whoa there it is
try the left oh die I want [ __ ] that
it's like no one can be less than a day
I've gotta be sticking a little work me
on the day or something oh I've lost all
my ability to destroy blocks by
minecraft crash eivol good even wait I'm
Marie making a blown Bob I've made like
three what are you making one for oh god
I can't I can't do this I can't do this
guys let's build a penis how dude it's
on fire man already no hang on it I put
it out it's light had a chance to like
go out into the world and make something
of itself
I got our penis is gonna go places in
life I kill not now if it's already
burning is this a double shafted penis
or something no ball I'm taking a wall
this is only a ball it's the real
emergency don't be herpes they don't
what you have herpes I'm so sorry I
can't destroy the penis I can only add
to it yeah I can't destroy blocks I can
only place bugs I don't understand
oh crap now it's got a side oh my god
what's happening
can't do this
you guys need to get it together you all
damaged it up again I'm just laughing it
more salty I think I'll use the word
frack I can't do this like it oh my gosh
I'm stuck
this is the best testicle I've ever made
out of wool this is my testicle your
testicle sucks
I've never made a test a lot of anything
else to be fair but I did it wouldn't
have looked this good
mmm other one just was tiny was like oh
it's you wrestled and not even connected
to the shadow I don't think you guys are
taking it seriously when you launch me
out of this again is there a better mod
for launching people on penises yet type
yes or yes
oh good baby no oh god oh my god you can
hear me zombie smite me art okay so
welcome back to drunk minecraft are we
just starting hey guys welcome we're
starting clean now okay this one we're
building a um a baby bottle pop out of
pink wool baby bottle pop baby bottle
pop way to dip the balls in from who's
it from from that commercial for baby
bottle what do you mean what is that
from wait is baby bottle pop the thing
yeah that's right it was the thing was
like you you even this unger powder and
then you oh do they still have that look
it that slip it then you dip it here's a
bottle pops - a bottle pop not sponsored
by baby bottle pop baby bottle bomb hey
ah stop your I didn't that is like the
most that's always copyrighted food
Gaga's gonna be fish oh
I though that is like the most 90s thing
though that is like so 90s that's not so
nineties there's no way that's more 90s
than space boots or whatever Space Jam
yeah well Space Jam yeah oh my gosh what
in the hell happened
yeah anyway everyone everyone Bella
Oh what everybody back up back up back
up I got my camisole in the middle of
I'm losing my headphones hold on guys
come back to let's play um the Minecraft
of drinking game and the last one we
blew up a penis and in this one we're
gonna start over
am I on cue I just blew up gonna blow up
this village ah you're only create radio
good let's still the house and create a
mellow poop and left in last okay
no one I'm gonna start it because I was
recording in the beforehand recording in
the beforehand
trust me this this is gotten strange I
don't know what I'm doing anymore I
think we all have a drinking contest Oh
pop you just got so loud no I all my my
volume got turned off my bad
that's my bad so much if I could fall
out of my chair I would fall out of mine
you guys missed it but it's recorded
somewhere
alright we got to finish this up super
which was the starter webcams nevermind
started it started we're good alright
okay serious mode guys serious MOCA
I'm building a glass house serious hydro
stone to Eagle Oh clever joke I'm also
Miss Julie Ann stone
because um creative mode mark you big
jerk
you're always destroying everything nice
alright so oh god I think we're almost
done for this part thing these last two
episodes we have it we haven't done
anything how do you statue get here what
where did this come from what I'm a
drill into your head and see if there's
anything there hey I'm gonna punch you
in the face
go it's Hollow uh I gotta try this again
parts mine you're killing me
my face is gone what's in your brain
okay and I gotta try this before we end
this okay hang on everybody shut up
four zillion zombie mold is wanted by
all my fans oh you idiot my fans think
zombie mold is the sexiest man alive and
they're gonna not stop until they still
live away from Latin goddess nope
nothing nothing good you deserve that
what the hell happened on your marks
getting this note head crush dude what
what up your shirt a little this is PG
yeah my fans want zombies huge dick whoa
I'm gonna blow up flatten drop mine
crash will never be back ever again
because our da lost our owner server guy
I'm not being smitten so I wore you
don't know what's happening
zombies probably being murdered for
still talking to you I don't know
nothing's happening I guess so hey
there's a horse and the Sheep go have
fun
have fun with yourself Go Go Golden
Apple all right I think I think we're
done okay the next one we're gonna do a
building competition we didn't even do
the walking yeah shut up mark you're
giving away all of our next three
episodes my horsey I want to surround
him with dandy oh yeah so thank you so
much Bob for being here Bob thank hahaha
no now wait at all nothing no nothing
wait we merely tolerate your presence
no wait since you ready hey no wait wait
real talk I'm Wade the drunk minecraft
would not be the same without you
I love you you are awesome you may look
camera right now I'm gonna say for the
record that I am pretty good at this
all right we're gonna go sleep this
alcohol off no I'm still got like dinner
and stuff I got plans man all right all
right
zombies you turn this all into TNT for
the big finale of our trunk
hahaha how many episodes is this like
seven this is the fourth oh my god we'd
even make it to five sabi we got to do
one more let's do the move shut up trick
next change our gal Virgil yeah
look at your distorted TNT face Mike
yeah I'm gonna throw it up my cheeks
hurt so much from smiling so much
hahaha it's gonna go it's gonna go Cabo
me oh great
wait wait I got this I missed it off
mine Oh God dodge look
I think I think well I have this moment
going on we should do it I think I'm
done record no you just need to do this
next time like that idea that Mark had
with the drinking at the start that was
great because I could tell you guys got
hit by it hard really good I still have
like half of a glass to go this is your
gonna end I think when I had my laughing
spell you knew so Miami Shh it wait how
much time do you have left
um I don't know I'm not had the MRI yet
hahahahahahaha dark joke dark joke
that's a full-blown Latins wrath too